good to meet you how are you feeling
today
i'm good i'm sitting in my house as i
have been for the past
six months so um yeah it's just like a
wild
a wild time if you could imagine yeah of
course
i want to start by talking about uh
heather
and like how ultimately relatable this
song
is just the idea of wanting to become
like the object of affection of your
object of affection
what type of response did you get from
fans
uh when they first heard the song
well i'd kind of been talking about the
song prior to the album
even coming out and the truth is it's it
was never a single it was just a random
song on the album but it was my favorite
song off of the album and
people's response you know when i wrote
the song i was really afraid of what
people were gonna
think because the song is not it's not a
very nice song
it's kind of a meme um and i was like oh
they're gonna say that i'm like
toxic and mean and i thought they were
gonna judge me but
i put the song around and everyone's
just like oh like i've been there and i
was like
oh cool so i'm not insane um it was it
was very
good to know that i wasn't the only one
who's who's felt that way and has felt
jealous of someone yeah
is it i mean you just mentioned the idea
of um
people saying that you might be toxic
because of a song that you're going to
put out a piece of art that you're
making
does that concept um
does that do you struggle with that does
that concept ever stop you
from making something that you feel in
your heart or that something you want to
say
absolutely i mean i think there's
definitely the thought crosses my mind
but apparently it doesn't really
resonate with me because i
do it anyways i don't know i think i
think that
with music in particular um you just
kind of have to be as honest as possible
i think people aren't stupid people can
tell if something's not real or or if
you don't actually believe what you're
saying
so um i try my best to just be as honest
as possible
to a fault now my personal life is
destroyed i have no idea what's going on
because everyone who talks to me is like
oh he's gonna write a song about me i'm
like maybe i will
just don't do me wrong and i won't write
a song about you
yeah that's interesting the the um you
know in the song you talk about wanting
to be
like somebody else and it almost
could be a song about becoming famous
if you think about it that way too like
wanting to become the object of
affection for
fans in a way do you feel the pressure
now that you are like nothing have all
these eyes on you to be
something that you didn't maybe that you
weren't yesterday
i think everybody feels a certain
pressure to
you know be a certain thing to people
you know if you've just met somebody
you're not going to be like here's all
my deepest darkest secrets and
you know that kind of thing and i think
yeah i mean
to just to say that there isn't pressure
would be just a
blatant lie i mean of course there's a
lot of pressure i feel like i'm
literally shrinking all the time it's
it's it's it's um
it's overwhelming but with the pressure
has come
so much love and so much support and
and to have all the fans be here and and
supporting me and being so kind um it
helps to drown out anything that
that makes me feel negatively and um
yeah but i think any i think any human
being um
feels pressure to be something but i try
my best to just be as real as possible
because
um you know you only get one shot to be
a
human in this life at least so might as
well
be what you are absolutely now the i
mean the comment section
um for heather is filled with people
that are saying they relate to the song
they know how how you feel um
i love the ones that are like if he's
not half as pretty as heather how pretty
is heather like that
is i think the funniest one to me i
think that's really great
um but you know you were also quick to
sort of respond to people that wanted to
um
make assumptions about you your
sexuality where your head is at why was
it important to you to respond to that
i think that for some reason people when
they listen to music they
at least my music and i think a lot of
people it's like they want to know
everything about the inner workings of a
song but i think to me
music is just music like a song means
what it means to you
when the song came out there all these
people like trying to find the real
heather and trying to like do this and
this isn't like
it doesn't actually matter though you
know like if the song means something to
you then like it can mean that to you
you know i wrote it about a certain
experience that i had
but if you have a specific experience
with it and like that's your
that's your experience and you're
allowed to have it and i think people
get so caught up in
all the drama and stuff that just
doesn't matter and um
i i just hope that people you know just
listen to the music and just let it be
what it needs to be for them yeah you
know one of the um
one of the people that's been giving you
a shout out is taylor swift and that
must sound
it must feel incredible to know that
like my understanding is that you grew
up
listening to her music and being a fan
and that there's a parallel there like
that is something that she's talked
about as well just letting the music
be the music is that something that you
internalize being a fan of hers or is
that something that you've just always
felt about music in general
i think i've always felt that way about
music you know um there was always a
part of me as a kid where like
i wouldn't want to look up the lyrics of
a song because i would mishear them and
i'd like the misheard lyrics a little
bit more than the actual lyrics and
things like that
but i think taylor in particular you
know um
she's just always been a massive
inspiration to me the way that she can
tell a story
um and say exactly what she wants to say
and i think that as a songwriter there's
a certain
you know there's a certain respect that
needs to exist where like
this is what i'm telling you this is
what i'm giving you and everything else
that you
are getting about the song you are
taking you know you're taking
so i think that like when you write a
song you say
exactly what you say in the song and
that's what you're given you know and
everything else
a little unnecessary and also like a
little bit mean a little intrusive
but it's also nice to you know to let
the listener
discover for themselves what it means to
them right
absolutely and you know the fact that
that
so many people have reached out and told
me that they relate to the song
has made me feel so much better because
when i wrote the song i felt so alone in
my experience
and um there's definitely a beautiful
thing about sharing your experiences
with
with a song or sharing how you relate to
the song and things like that because
it really is music is a beautiful
unanimous experience like
everybody gets to enjoy a song you know
and so um
there's definitely um so much beauty in
it and
i'm so grateful that anybody cares you
know um
the fact that people are wanting to dig
into it is just like
i mean i i do you know i do understand
and
and um i think that it's um it's just a
beautiful thing to have people care so
much
yeah um kid crow has
i find that there's like diverse sound
in kid crow
and it's obviously a collection of
stories but is there um
a theme or an overarching message with
that collection of stories
i think that kid crow to me was just
kind of a coming-of-age
story you know i i wrote it about my
started writing at my freshman year of
college and
um it's just about this weird in between
of
of being a child but also being an adult
and kind of like the weird mixture and
also when you're young
your experiences are just so visceral
like you know like one little thing
happens someone doesn't text you back
and you're like
ah it's the end of the world
um it's it's that feeling and i think
that anybody
who's ever existed can relate to that
and um the album is just becoming a vape
story to me it's kind of my introduction
into the world
i didn't want to overspeak i didn't want
to um
i didn't want to give too much i just
want to be like this is this is who i am
take it or leave it i guess
yeah and aside from you know getting
attention from
all those fans and some like taylor
swift but you're getting attention from
elton john as well like
all these legends is that like how does
that feel to you how does your mind
how do you wrap your head around all of
that it's surreal you know
um i think that anytime anybody
says anything nice about what i do it's
it's always gonna be surreal and and i'm
always going to be grateful because
nobody needs to say nice things you know
um and and to have someone like elton or
or taylor who are just
so just so legendary and and so
important to so many people's lives and
you know basically raised entire
generations under the wings of their
music it's
it just means so much to me and and i i
never want to take that for granted it's
just
always so surreal and i text all my
friends i'm like oh my god in the world
it's just it's just exciting and um
those people raised me and i'm just
grateful for them yeah
the people that are closest to you those
friends that you're talking about and
your family
what is their reaction to all this
attention that you're getting
all the everything that's happening to
you right now my friends think it's
hilarious
um they're the first ones to just drag
me back down to her
a little too up in the clouds they're
just like
yeah conan but i remember when you were
in middle school and all you were was
that one gray shirt every day
like they're they're they're very um
they're they're they're my biggest
cheerleaders but they're also my biggest
haters
and i appreciate that i think that um
they're very excited for me and
um everybody from my past has been so
kind um it's very weird nobody expected
it
nobody from middle school would have
ever thought that any of this would have
happened so
um they're just very excited for me and
i love them they're the people who keep
me feeling like myself
nice to have that for balance right yeah
so what do you see moving forward
are you like picturing five years from
now ten years from now what you want
things to look like what you want your
career to be like
i never thought i'd make it this far
um it's hard for me because this is this
is more than i ever expected
ever i honestly didn't even think i'd
live this long so
to say that i have a five-year plan
would be a little insane because i can't
even like really think of what i'm going
to do tomorrow
um but if anything i just hope that i
make good music
and that people find comfort in and what
i make you know i find comfort in making
the songs
um and i just hope that i'm that i'm
happy i hope that i get to tour a bunch
and meet a bunch of people
and i hope that i fall in love i hope
that all of the normal human things
happen
um and yeah i just want to make a bunch
of music